la molinières porte bien son nom à
l'entrée de la propriété
la maquette d'un moulin à vent chen et
douglas du plus bel effet plus loin la
présence imposante d'un vestige cette
meule de près de 2 tonnes a été
fortuitement découvertes par des
ouvriers durant des travaux d'excavation
si elle ne parle pas elle raconte une
histoire
à chaque fois que cas moulin a été
démonté détruit
les gens enterrait la meule à l'endroit
où il y avait eu le moulin et c'est le
seul vestige qui prouve en en dehors des
écrits sur les cartes de la commune
c'est le seul vestige concrets qui nous
qui nous pour vraiment qu'il y avait
moins ici quoi
petit à petit va germer l'idée de
reconstruire à l'identique à moulins
vent sur cette terre un rêve vous à défi
insensé mais rien n'arrête la
détermination d'alberto 20
ce moulin représente
douze années de travail déjà pour
commencer et c'est vrai que ça
représente quand même beaucoup d'heures
de travail ça représente beaucoup
d'efforts mais bon c'est
faut dire que j'en tire une certaine
fierté mais mais ça me fait quand même
plaisir de loi sur place qu il n'y a pas
de doute un tout est en fait partie
d'une vieille carte postale découverte
dans un vide greniers alberto va
l'achète à 60 euros car il a reconnu sa
propriété c'est la preuve irréfutable
comme moulin à vent a bien existé au 19e
siècle à la mouline hyères la jav est
avait de quoi refaire le moulin j'ai
compris en pâture de voix c'est prévu
dans mon mari collectionner tout ou à
peu près il a su que le château vers
vous et remettre son ou la
reconstruction en construction et en
voilà et alors il lui a proposé de lui
fournir les documents qu'il avait pour
qu'ils puissent s'en servir noir c'est
comme quand michel petit m'a dit moi
j'ai les plans faut absolument que vous
ne fassiez moi j'ai les plans des
moulins à vent sur pivot
une épine du pied quand même
c'est en 2007 que véritablement démarre
les travaux
le bois coûte cher les matériaux aussi
malgré différentes et sa propre cagnotte
au moins soixante mille euros seront
dépensés et pourtant l'homme et
parcimonie dans un livre a réalisé par
sa fille est abondamment illustré
christine rollet raconte derrière son
objectif des temps forts de ce chantier
le moulin d'alberto va est une pièce
unique 5 mètre soixante sur 3 mètres 40
et 35 tonnes de bois utilisés
bon alors là on est vraiment dans le
coeur du moulin c'est le vraiment le
moteur
le moteur en bois qui permet de faire de
la farine ladsous il ya de mela et
chaque mâle pesant une tonne 4 donc
c'est quand même après la toiture mais
la toiture c'est une partie du bâtiment
dont café 2 tonnes ben si c'est aussi
une partie qui a été montée du sol
jusque là aux directement si c'était ça
le but c'est de moudre ses terres la
farine avec quand même donc là il est en
capacité de si on avait du vent puis
qu'on enclenche le pignon là on met du
blé et et on récupère de la farine en
dessous à souligner en sologne la
construction d'un moulin à vent par la
volonté d'un homme suscite curieux dire
enfin l'euro moi et puis bon il et kim a
et fonctionne en cuir parmi les
admiratrices madame le maire elle a bien
perçu pour sa commune l'intérêt
patrimonial et la visibilité que ce
moulin pourrait avoir dans les guides
touristiques
on a beaucoup de chance d'avoir
quelqu'un comme alberto 20 sur à
souvigny c'est quelqu'un qui sait tout
faire et le jour où il a décidé de
remettre de reconstruire le moulin tout
le monde était enchanté tout le monde
était ravi on a dit ça y est un morceau
du patrimoine de la commune qui revient
et donc ça c'est merveilleux que qu'il
ait pu faire ça et en plus c'est lui qui
l'a construit on va dire tout seul même
si il avait des copains qui donnait des
coups de main de temps en temps et c'est
exceptionnel alberto va a le triomphe
modeste pour aller au bout de son défi
il a dû tour à tour se ferme à son
charpentier ferronnier ou forgeron à 60
saison ce bourreau de travail gardent
une flamme intérieure
vous pensé à une reconversion
oui oui bah oui pour ma vie future moi
j'ai demandé à avoir une carte de
meunier bon je sais pas si ça va être
acceptée mais bon comme mais comme je
suis comme les chats g7 vit normalement
donc bah j'espère quoi compte il n'a pas
la tête dans les nuages
alberto va revient sur le plancher des
vaches à ses heures perdues il est
également trompettiste et organise
autour de son moulin un événement festif
et musical
une fois par an